hello and welcome to our expert webinar
data science and analytics in it service
management
our guest today is amal mahamuni of ibm
india
and our host today is our associate
director of
product at simply learn and i'll
just give you a few quick instructions
on how to
navigate webex the question mark
button allows you to enter questions for
them all
we will compile these and
we'll be taking them during the
presentation
and toward the end so please enter your
questions there
um the chat window if you have an urgent
message
for the panelists please use
the all panelist setting and
we will be able to see your message um
the chat messages are not shared with
the rest of the audience
and with that i will turn it over
to shivam to introduce ammo
[Music]
thank you stuart hi hi everybody
welcome good morning good evening uh so
we have
with us a mode is a program director at
uh right now at ibm and uh with over 33
years of experience he has
a vascular experience around cognitive
solutions data science
and has actually you know uh
done some deep work around it
infrastructure management
and the the cognitive science related to
it the
the data science related to it uh
developing all the solutions around
it's it's a pleasure to have your moles
here
and we look forward to a great talk with
you
uh yeah so uh quickly uh you know
uh getting getting started on this and
uh you know
one thing that we see across this
ecosystem and let's let's start from the
base there's a a lot of you know
buzz around ai machine learning deep
learning
uh so you know can you can you help us
understand it
the kind of pace of change that we have
seen in past few years is
actually we say that what has changed in
the last 10 years is far
beyond what has changed in the last 50
years it's definitely more than that and
data science ndi plays
definitely a very important role in that
so can you help us
understand what this basically is what
is the difference between a
ml deep learning uh this buzzword that
we hear
and what are the applications uh if you
can just
uh as as a starting point for some light
on that would be helpful
here thanks shivam and thanks um
so let me first get started i think
that's an interesting question right
which is
um you know what exactly is the iml
and is this something new right it's
something which is only happening and
why now right
so if i were to define of course you
will find
many of the mariam websters and you know
many of the definitions of it
but to me ai is simply it's a cognitive
system
you can understand which can learn uh
which can interact
with us and uh which can reason which
can explain
right substantiate what it is right the
machine learning is an application of
ami
or an ability to automatically learn and
improve all the time
um when explicitly programmed of course
right it needs a lot of training data
and it can only do what it's trained on
which in a way is
very focused you can only perform as
much as we've been trained
on a certain domain right uh deep
learning obviously is
as we really go into the multiple layers
of uh any
of the convolutional neural networks and
neurons are
um or the perceptrons are basically
those
are the fundamental building blocks of
all of this network which is exactly the
way
our human brain is wired right and we
are basically trying to emulate that in
a way right
but if i were to answer shivam is this
something new is
something which wasn't there i do recall
that you know before
joining ibm i've been live about 25
years in ibm but prior to that i was in
indian space research
for little over seven years and um i
think it was in 1990s or so so must have
been like 30 years back that
i was playing with hopkins models and i
was trying to see
how a cloud cover from an optical image
sensing
can actually or an export system on
cloud cover can tell us
whether that imagery is useful or not
useful right and it's not
as simple a problem that you take a
standard deviation and find out what's
the kind of you know the cover which is
sprinkled across the image
uh so the neural networks has been there
right since then i even prior to that
right
actually the history goes back to um you
know as
we all know in the computer science
field
uh there is uh the turing or the acm
turing award has
equal into that of a nobel award right
and the reason we call it a tutoring
award is somewhere
almost 50 years back uh alan turing had
the first turing test
and there was this during uh you know
the the paradigm of what a compute
machine should be
and then the multiple things happened
there on and there are few things which
i can certainly
cite to being in ibm for a while and few
of those are very very interesting as a
matter of fact
uh the term as an ai actually came
somewhere in 1960s
which as many of us know came from the
dart smart conference which was nearly
eight week conference and
they're basically trying to look at
thinking machines can there be a
thinking machine and if there is a
thinking machine what can that be right
so that's where she on this whole term
of artificial intelligence because it's
not natural intelligence
and then the multiple rendering of that
concept which happened
one of the things that i distinctly
recall being in ibm at that time was
it was in 1997 that's the first time
that there was a human computer
chess and gary casper who was
the grandmaster that time was beaten by
something called ibm deep blue
so that was one of those but you know
more importantly and more interestingly
than that if i put an example about
you know the whole thing about the the
artificial intelligences
in 2011 2012 there was a very
interesting game and that's
uh stuart you may be aware that's a game
called dupadi
and uh that's a televised game as much
fact and geoparty does mean that
there is a question which is asked uh as
a rapid fire question
and that question has a hint it's not
direct question what flows down the hill
for instance right
now there could be multiple things which
can float on the hill any liquid could
uh and then you have to answer on a
buzzer route so if you are the first one
you get to answer and if you're good
if your answer is right you get masked
right and that was the first time that
again there was a human computer
interface and ibm watson
won the g party game so that was in 2011
2012 and then there was you know many
other things right
but net net the question is why now
right
uh the stochastic gradient descent
actually as we know came
out way back in 1950s the multi layer
perceptron came in the deep cnns were in
95
but the gpus the tpus the npus and the
whole compute bar
the whole paradigm of trying to run this
on the cloud
the data sets that we have from kaggle
today
the whole you know keras tensorflow
libraries all of these
ingredients of a recipe actually weren't
there together
for it to actually be gaining traction
as much as it has been today
so i would say it's not as new uh but of
course it's becoming more relevant today
yeah yeah about i i completely get that
i think uh the kind of problems that we
are solving now with the increased
computational power
but with evolved algorithm has
definitely changed
uh what uh we could not think of 10
years back is becoming solvable
uh with ai so one uh related aspect
common to it
is do you think we have reached a stage
where
almost 90 percent of the problems or 80
percent of the problems are everything
around can be solved with ai
uh is has a reason that's ever still
there is that evolution needs to happen
a lot
uh very good question and actually
before i answer the question let me take
a little bit of a detail because it
would be quite interesting to the
audience as well
yeah as we're really looking at this
compute power and the gpus and tpus and
you know all of these coming up right
which can actually solve the complex
mathematical problem for us so the
statistical
problems for us like the matrix
inversion is a very statistical error
processing kind of problem right
uh we are actually looking at something
which is going to be coming in near
future
and if i really quickly quickly take a
detail to quantum computing for instance
right
um and where is quantum computing headed
uh quantum as
uh we all understand right it's not just
the binary state
it's not just about the yes no or zero
one kind of a state
but it's something which is a part state
so something which
if you really spin a coin for instance
uh is it zero or one
at the time that it is spinning right
maybe it is either zero
or one and it could be anything in
between right and that's exactly what
the quantum computing is
and my company ibm has
has surged ahead in that as a matter of
fact we have 50 qubits as we call
it and they're different different
quantum models i would say but
50 cubits is all that we can do today
but the reason quantum is extremely
important and the reason is relevant to
your question as well is
we believe that when the quantum
computer becomes the reality for that
matter that is
50 qubits which is launched right in
2019 uh we probably need
maybe a couple of uh thousand cubits so
it's it's the way to go
however when we get that it could be
something
if i'm going to put something which is
like 100 million times faster
than today's computer right so it's
going to change the whole landscape
of the complex algorithms which you can
actually make right and of course
there are issues which are trying to
wrestle down to the ground which is the
superposition
uh it actually works at one degree
kelvin which is almost at the absolute
zero right and maintaining that and
maintaining coherence of qubits is a big
problem
but to come to that you know of course
the quantum is yet to happen but that
could be a game changer
are is ais following all the problems
today uh
well i mean we i wouldn't say it's a
magic bullet
of course um you know you would have
heard about uh very recently
i think it was in december last year
there was an auction of an
ai painted you know painting right and
ai painting i would say
we just sold for 430k right we just
closed about half million dollars so
it's great
we can hear that here say i can write
poems and i can be very creative in all
of it
but um while we say that there are
challenges in here and there are going
to be challenges right the challenges
could be
again obtaining the large volume of a
data that too from disparate sources
right and you have multiple sources
we'll talk
more in ids and contact the whole
explainability and
um you know the model algorithm has to
reason for
what it does um and then the whole
you know the ethically i i can talk a
little bit more about it
so there is this about the morality of
the ai
and a lot of discussions which are
happening about the weaponization in
there
uh we heard about you know a few of the
things which is the fairness in the
whole ai model
uh but more than that it is about the
emotions it's about again the creativity
uh and of course you know the other
things about data and security and
everything so i would say that ai is
certainly evolving
uh it's not at a stage at which we can
say uh it's replacing humans absolutely
not
uh it's something which can be used to
assist what we do today
yeah it started with automation uh it
will go you know a little more in
even creating those cognitive skills and
you know you've seen this
like autonomous car is more or less a
reality today a few of these
you know i would say something which we
had always classified as
only humans can do or human brains can
do is starting to happen but again there
are miles to go so
it's not that we are reached at a stage
at which uh we can say
despite the fact we can say is
ubiquitous today it's not something
which is
um i would say threat to humanity yeah
yeah
got it uh i think uh uh very very very
fair
thought on that and uh while i believe
uh we still have some way to go let's
just ask our audience
what do they believe uh so if you can
open a pole sword the question is that
uh can ai replace humans today
we'll just give two minutes for this
bone and let's let's hear what our
audience has to say
that's an interesting question really
i would like to see what the audience
says yeah
yeah we'll keep the poll open for about
another minute
are getting a number of answers
so after you make your selection
remember to hit submit
see a couple of people responding in the
chat window please
respond in the poll window
then we'll count we'll be able to count
your response in the totals
and we'll close the poll in about 20
seconds here
actually belong to that is something
called freight action which is fair
accountable transparent and ethical ai
okay
so there's a lot of work actually um
many corporations do
including ibm on what we really call as
you know the
fairness of the and the ethical behavior
of the
morals of the yeah okay so that could be
topic by itself
yeah yeah we'll definitely go there
we'll talk about ethical ai also
give me a moment i'll be able to share
the uh
answer sure sure there we go
it's kind of uh in some cases okay
i like that i like that of course only
in some cases right and uh
you know if i just export to that um we
uh if i give an example of an i.t
service management which is what is the
focus of today's discussion
uh there was this kind of an automation
which is our ability to react to a given
problem
and as fast as it can be right we're
just closing a ticket for instance right
yeah uh or making something more
resilient and reliable with better
upcoming with the lights on
and of course to that extent the
programmability that we are able to put
into this systems
is helping us to keep the lights on
for us to be able to automate
certain uh i would say from the um
there is a legacy perspective an uptime
perspective uh certain tickets or
certain alerts dispositioning of the
alerts
uh so that is certainly happening uh
again there are more ways to go
uh we can talk a little more when i come
to rightly some context
sure sure uh that's that's helpful so
let's let's just move on on to the
uh you know uh next where we know when
we talk about
data science ai machine learning and the
whole
industry right now is on you know having
that competitive advantage
delivering a smooth customer experience
the customer experience plays a very
critical role
so uh you know translating that to it
service management
at the itsm and most of us specifically
here
uh in bangalore from iit background and
we have heard this term a lot
and we have been through uh you know
this this cycle but
uh what do you think you think uh how
has itsm
and the service industry changed over
the years uh
adopted ai and machine learning uh
specifically what are the trends and
opportunities you see here
uh with the with uh with the increased
expectations
of the customer and the customer service
that we want to deliver
uh and what are the new business areas
and
you know changing business models around
this so if you can throw some light
on how itsm is changing this uh
how itsm is taking this as a change and
how what what are the different models
being incorporated
that would be helpful i think that's it
that's a terrific question right yeah
because that's something which is close
to our heart and that's that's part of
what you're doing
so i'll start with itsm first and maybe
i'll dwell a little deeper into the air
suspect of a
yeah and the many uh many words
which are coined in the industry today
uh we'll go a little more on the apps
but uh
of course there is chat ups and there is
apops and then there is of course you
know the all variants of the devops
yeah and the office and sre as a concept
is kind of emerging together as a site
reliability engineering
uh going towards the ml ops and model
ops and auto ops and all of it right but
let's just talk about you know what is
id service management industry and um
you know what are the trends you talked
about
you know what are the trains and
opportunities right so i would say
um exactly as the audience also stated
right ai does help
in some cases certainly not all and yeah
that's so true right
so there is a journey that we started
from
i would say from a system of requests to
the system of engagement to
the system of insights right so that is
the
the system of records which is the data
at rest which has to speak to you
and as it was said right the
data is the new uh gold mine right
it's something which is the the biggest
natural resources people call it right
yeah so it's the next natural resource
which allows you to go from
something like a bi to pi to ci and the
reason i say this is
something which is business intelligence
or a business analytic to that of
predictive which is more statistical
modeling
to that of cognitive right so that is a
bici kind of a journey
uh which is in a way if i really relate
that it's going from
reactive to more proactive
and uh even a step better which is
prevented you right
so gone are the days when um i could uh
grab your
touch would not me but somebody right
could go to a doctor when they don't
feel good and they get some antibiotic
and then they pop the pills and they say
wow right within two days i could
actually cure myself
to going to a state where i can actually
be more proactive maybe i could be
exercising more or whatever it is
and then be able to procrastinate or
differ
these things hitting me or better still
if i actually go to the grassroots which
is preventative right
yeah which is from a trained perspective
it is reactive to proactive to
preventative which is probably trying to
go far without what it is right which is
the best ticket as we call it in itsm is
the one that you haven't gotten right
it's the same thing like the best
disease is the one or the best medicine
sorry
is the one that you don't have to pop
the pill for right now why is it
happening and how is it changing right
um uh if i really look at an opportunity
over here right
we call it you know the four v's of the
big data analytics which is the volume
there is a huge volume
and uh we'll just talk about a volume in
a second but there is a volume and there
is a velocity
there is a variety and then the velocity
right
uh the volume is obviously we're looking
at a huge volume uh
even that kind of you know every
challenge has an opportunity but i would
call it as an opportunity more than a
challenge right
so you can see that uh we are about five
billion mobile phones
difficult to believe but you know in a
six billion population we have five
million mobiles phone
nearly four billion internet users the
data generated here
today uh which is close to 1.5 2.5 to 3
exabytes
depending on which report you read which
is expected to go to 400 exabytes right
and 5 billion videos are watched in
youtube every single day so we are
really looking at a huge volume over
here right yeah now from the volume
we are also talking of uh the use case
such as a fraud right which would be an
internet for
which would be a trade card which could
be you know any of the security threat
which needs to be handled in real time
and when you're talking of a real-time
data we're talking about velocity of
data right
now you need to have the iot systems
which can ingest the data at the rate at
which it is coming in
be able to analyze it decipher it and be
able to enact on it right get those
insights to act on it right
you don't want somebody who is um you
know unethical or whatever it is you
know or terrorist for instance to be
able to board a plane right so it needs
to be arrested in time
nearly a time right so those are the
kind of things that we're talking about
from an opportunity perspective
uh and the mindset uh you you talked
about the mindset right
from a mindset of course there is uh
exploitation of ai
all over the world actually you touch
any phase facet of the life today
it is touched from the speed from the
agility from the quality from the cost
perspective by ai
as i said there is a move from
automation to resilient infrastructure
to rather self-healing infrastructure
right and from an itsm if i really draw
that analogy it is about the typical
society
yeah now can the ticketless city happen
today absolutely not
uh but are there um are these is there
an evolution which is actually touching
that absolutely us and we can talk in a
little more details on that
lastly i think you talked about what are
the new business areas right
um so i'll go back to the itsm which is
the focus here
uh the monitoring today is largely
independent
siloed monitoring and the data
engineering aspect
is i think a major aspect of it when you
will talk of data engineering and data
science and then data visualization
the other three legged stool and we have
three basic tenets of it
um these um the i
i would say from a mission critical
application supporting perspective is
becoming very crucial
for us to uh deploy ai underneath
and i can also show you a couple of use
cases as we go a little more
but suffice it to say that as the world
is going from
the bare metals to that of the vms to
that of the cloud native
uh which is whole containerized to that
of serverless computing and open waste
we are looking at the journey supported
by the big data analytics and the ai
backbone
so that's where we headed let me just
quote another interesting example i
don't know they heard about it but
very recently ibm and promair are in
partnership
to launch first autonomous ship
it's not uh it's not the teslas of the
world but it's not on our ship called
mayflower 400. okay something which is
going to go on a solo voyage
which is a driverless ship if you will
right trying to do some arctic
exploration so
we'll see how it goes awesome i hope
that that's a that's a
it's a good use case and uh we will will
look forward to it
uh well you talked about a very critical
point that
data is the new natural resource we say
data is a new oil
i would say like plumbing of data is
data engineering and making sense of
data is
data science machine learning against
across different you know uh
facets of our life uh now open up let's
let's let's take an opinion from our
audience also we we spoke about ai we
spoke about machine learning and you
also talked about ai being exploited
also at some places so uh let me let me
ask this poll to
the audience that uh do you guys think
is ai a bone or a pain
uh you know uh if if you can uh
just quickly respond on that and we'll
definitely discuss on that
just just want to want to hear thank you
stuart for putting that's a great
question
yeah i mean so much that yeah i can help
us here can also be kind of treated with
the threat so he's
right i think that's a great question
yeah with uh a lot of uh you know we
have seen across the ecosystem you know
apps getting banned and everything data
sharing becoming
uh a lot of problems so you know uh from
a pia perspective
and also we'll touch upon ethically i
also don't
down the conversation but just wanted to
hear from the audience
you have about 10 seconds to finish
and if i read out the choices easy
good thing for the world and does some
good things but it has its own risks of
course you know many good things come
with its own risk
and it's more risky than beneficial so
stay away from that
and it is dangerous and strictly
controlled okay
i think fourth is an extreme one let's
see
you know i think this is the time with
all the presidential poll debates which
are happening
what is the kind of an opinion poll over
here oh as expected
yeah it's good in some aspect of it
obviously you know
any good thing as as it goes right has
to be kind of handled with care and
ordering of that
and i see maximum responses over here so
nearly five people can say yep i think
that makes sense yes
thank you thank you audience and thank
you so uh let's let's quickly
moving forward i would you you touched
upon uh something called ai ops
uh can you help us understand it better
uh related to it infrastructure
management operations
if you can help us understand it better
oh yeah oh yeah sure i think that's a
kind of a logical segue right
and i mentioned couple of things as a
matter of fact right there is ai ops and
then there is a devops and then there
are multiple other things like that apps
and app
so what have you right model apps and
yeah but i think the crux of it is uh
we're basically looking at
the data which is again extremely
important insights
and inference and the insights right and
the automation
so aiops is about combining the big data
and machine learning together primarily
to automate the idea operation processes
right
including event correlation including
anomaly detection
causality uh stuff of that kind right so
primarily looking at
how the data speaks to you from a
business context
yeah and of course there are different
models that we use there are different
algorithms and it has evolved over the
time
they could be the supervised learning
technique shivam which could be
anything like logistic regressions dc
and clean air base
isolation forest whatever and of course
supervised is
not always possible quite often because
you need labeling of the data
and when you're talking of millions of
records becomes extremely difficult
uh and unsupervised techniques like a
means uh you know
any of the dimensionality reactions like
pca all of that kind of comes handy
there could be you know different
classification algorithms that we use
but more primarily i think we are all
gravitating towards convolutional neural
networks recurrent neural networks
rnns quite often that we use in aiops
and i'll talk about that which is
lstm gru htm or arimas
so what i'll do is rather let me
if i'm able to share the slides let me
just pick few slides and kind of talk
through it
because that brings the context to the
whole app so
i just wanted to share a couple of
slides and i think i should be able to
share my screen no not yet
yeah no no you should be able to i
should be able to oh yeah yeah yeah
there you go
yes um so
tell me if it is visible
yeah did you see this lines okay okay so
assume i didn't want to do
this death by powerpoint to be honest
but um at least you know want to take
you know a few of the slides just to
bring the context right
uh so i'll just use couple of slides
over here to talk about uh
what is uh the airapps platform right
and what you see over here is
there are a lot of so the basic tenets
of it from the app's perspective is
of course you have the platform you have
the big data
and you have the big analytics over
there and the big data could be
you know any which way you have any
distributed file systems and again the
four
v's that we talked about right the
fourth three i forgot to touch is a very
important way
so we talked about the volume and the
velocity and the variety right because
these resources that you kind of you
know trade rate across and get the data
together
uh there are a lot of challenges when
you talk after data engineering right
because it goes all the way
from your ability to extract the data
which is etl the data be able to
transform the data
and then the data imputation then the
data wrangling
and this data transformation and this
data enrichment and you know whole nine
years away
before you go to a common normalized
data model
which then can feed into the analytics
engine right so the whole data
preparation stage itself
is quite challenging particularly given
so when there are so many disparate and
variety of the tools which are existing
in ecosystem right
yeah and that gives another challenge
which is disparate tools right and there
are different monitoring tools and there
are different observatory
observability tools and there are
different performance measurement tools
and all of it
and then the observability platform for
you to be able to monitor infrastructure
becomes a very important thing
particularly if it is possible to be on
a single pane of glass right yeah
and then we can go to the service desk
which is the engaged part of it so this
is a loop which is observe
engage and act right and the reason it
is a continuous loop
is the way our cognitive systems work
right the first time shivam you probably
you are me both of us right when we
first we're behind the wheels
we kind of go a little bit to the right
and then little bit to the left and then
we kind of adjust to it because there's
a continuous feedback right yeah yeah so
that's exactly what we're talking over
here
and what you see in the middle is
basically coming in from gartner
so from an observability perspective of
course there are
multiple things which the it industry
has been doing
uh which is looking at the historical
data and be able to analyze the data
and it's not just about the historical
time series data availability right it's
about the continuous data which is
available
which is the quality data right so data
quality is another very important issue
over here from an its mrap specifically
for us to be able to get the data to
train our models right if i i get
recalled of one of the client
conversations
where i was talking about something
called model prediction right and the
prediction accuracy
and accuracy in our term we call it
precision and recall right and the
precision of a model we said well it can
be like 85 to 90 percent
and it was like boom so you can actually
see 85
of the tickets which i get in my system
you can detect i said no i didn't say
that
yeah because the model can only predict
what you get
you can get one year of a data but if
there is no intent if there is no
incident which has ever happened there
is no way for the model to predict it
to get that level of accuracy of course
the model can still predict it
it wouldn't have that 85 percent
accuracy right so we've got to be a
little careful in what we say but
that's about the historical data
analysis which allows us to do some
predictions right
and of course you know many of these
things when we really look at
the analysis of the data uh which is
where the anomaly detection comes and
many of these things are pretty
compounded
by the complexity of the fact over here
so if i talk about the performance drift
analytics or the
contextual analysis and you know complex
correlation
if i just give a couple of examples away
right um
there was a time in which we can say any
anomalous behavior any outlier
is an anomaly right and we can detect an
anomaly by having something as we call
as
lsl usl kind of a thing right it kinds
of crosses an upper bound and say boom
you know cut a ticket and cut a lot
right
of course that's not the way what
cognitive systems should do right
you need to understand and learn over
the time that quite often
when you really cross maybe even 90
percent of a cpu
you don't cut a ticket because it is an
expected behavior whenever there is a
bur process going on or a backup which
is going on right
yeah so in our parallel we call it false
ticket right so we need to be able to
avoid the false ticket
and hence we need dynamic thresholding
for the anomaly detection right so it's
pretty complex
similarly when you talk of correlation
it's not just about looking at a single
variable of a system
right and when it's a single variable of
a system you're not just looking at a
cpu spike or just the rate of change of
a slope right
or its memory or it is higher rate or
whatever it is in a port and a volume or
node or whatever it is in storage
it's not about that right it's about an
ability to correlate many of those
things together which is basically a
multivariate correlation
to be able to qualify a certain alert to
be a genuine knowledge to cut educate
and only then it should be passed on to
the humans or whichever automation suite
that you got right
so that's what we're talking on the left
hand side from the observability
perspective and if i go to the right
hand side over here
which is the entire automation and you
know you would have heard about sleep
automation
although from robotic process automation
like blue prism and automation anywhere
uh to anything which we call as dynamic
automation based on ibsoft which has
you know a bunch of cautious scripts it
has an ability to use a password what
enable you to actually
go down into you know the software
distribution way it could be
you know any which way that you do the
task automation right it could be chef
recipes it could be salt or puppet
or you know just just um you know any
which way we
use through bigfix for instance right
and there's a change risk analysis there
is knowledge management again there is a
lot which is happening in knowledge
management that goes to the chat ops
again right
yeah which is how this harvesting of a
knowledge and creating a knowledge
purpose
can then be ingested into a kb which has
its own taxonomy and an anthology
and then on the ontology you can
actually define certain functions for
you
uh to be able to converse right and
actually i i get recalled that
again we can argue that it's not new i
think the first time i heard about it
was somewhere in 1958 there was
something called project eliza
which was actually able to talk to you
right and of course today there are many
ivr systems which can talk to you
including siri which many of us have
seen right but that's the landscape that
we're talking
and everything that's has its own
complexity in the itu operations
management sphere so if i just pick one
out of it right
so what you can see shivam on the
left-hand side is um you know the
different monitoring tools and we talked
about it i want to slow one more slide
just just to give you a feel of
it yeah and then the rc right so let's
look at the causality right
um and we talked about this journey from
bi to pi to ci
with an explainability reasoning
interpretability and all of it
so the root cause analysis post failure
is an important thing because when we
really look at
an incident which is happening or a
ticket which has been cut in an i.t
service management
a ticket is my memory is full my disk is
full as a ticket right
then you can go and probably fulfill the
ticket by doing what on earth can you do
for a disk being full right
you can post it or you can probably
delete it or you can archive it which
are the way right
but you still probably haven't addressed
the root cause
by clearing the disk you're not getting
away with it because another half an
hour you'll probably get the alert again
and again
right yeah so from an rca perspective
which is root cause you actually have to
go to what we call
as five eyes right why did this happen
and then you go to the next question
which is well this is the reason it
happened right
how did this get full because there is
an agent which is spurious which is
trying to do more memory swap or
whatever now why is there a swap
and then you go to the next so you
create a situation
and then you go to the root cause and
then you attack the root of it
which actually solves the problem from a
long-term perspective right so i just
wanted to give
one example of there and that's exactly
what we really do from an i.t operations
management perspective
so i'll probably not spend much time on
this but that's exactly
what i was talking earlier which is
going from descriptive to prescription
okay it's good enough or it was good
enough here
right maybe you know a few years back in
yesteryears to be able to say
what has happened right which is in the
parlance of it service management again
we can say here is a kind of you know
the defect density per server
no well that's good but that's not good
enough what do i do with it
i mean i get more defects over there and
is it because
it's an aging system and it's an old
hack that i need to replace
or is it because there is some other
challenge in routing or is there
something else which is happening going
up the capacity or whatever it is right
so the next step is again diagnostic
which is diagnose the problem which is
why is it happening now that you know
what is happening why is it happening
yeah and go to the next step which is
more statistical predictive calculus
which is uh you know i myself call it a
spss kind of a calculus right that's one
of the things that is an acquisition
which are basically statistical models
like ngfi could be a simple example of
that right
yeah uh it's not so much of the gradient
boosting but
a very simple forward interpolation uh
but that still helps you
what will happen in your future with no
learning component there
right and that's where the machine
learning comes in and then we go to this
you know the nirvana state which could
be
you know the understanding of the deep
machine learning and the reason we call
it deep learning
is the depth of the hidden layers right
which is how many
the back propagation or the forward
propagation that you can have yeah and
how many of this
you know the perceptrons are the neurons
that you can actually wire together
that's the kind of a deep learning
because beyond the point your linear
learning actually block tools right
that's a prescriptive thing so that is
again
in a way going from i just want to use
one last slide um
this hyper we can flash because there
are multiple things that we really talk
from um
ai ops perspective or operational
analytics uh there are quite a few of
things i think i gave a few examples
over here maybe
i give one more example right uh which
is uh
data center for instance i'll just speak
one example over here before i go to
last slide
so from a data center i'll just see a
time check real quick okay
i'll just quickly wrap this up so you
know one of the very interest
interesting factors that we started
working here recently is
in addition to what we are concentrating
today on a data center can we also look
at the data
center facilities perspective which is
your air conditioner
cooler chillers stuff of that kind right
and surprising that it may sound but
35 to 40 percent of the energy and data
center is not used by the machines which
are actually complete machines and a
storage network
but it's an energy which is spent in
just cooling that entire infrastructure
and if you really get the right set
point and i'm kind of going little more
towards the iot or the telemetry data
over here
and in a way i think that's a natural
progression right when we're really
talking about the back end analytics
uh very soon we'll be so we are actually
today talking about the asian analytics
right and
there are different um platforms which
are emerging the different techniques
which are emerging
something like xh and cube agent you
know within ibm we call it project
horizon
uh which is again an open source and we
use that um
uh but the age i t with the advent of ig
is rendering itself very easily
towards the 5g towards iot that's the
telemetry data right that's the space of
sensors and actuators
which could be anything like autonomous
cars to the drill machines or what have
you
and when we really talk of the data
center facilities management these iot
census data can be monitored in real
time
which is all the lvdt's the differential
transformers or sensors actuators
and be able to optimize the set point of
your chiller
time in real time which in
our experience which we had one of our
reference plant in hong kong be about 25
percent efficiency
25 of the energy which is 35 percent of
the consumption is not just a huge
saving
but very you know probably that's not
topic that we wanted to talk about but
you know we are going to be mandated for
our offspring and i think majority of
the participants could be young so
for the gen y about the karma footprint
right it's not
of course we can argue whether it's an
atomic energy or hydraulic energy or
thermal energy but at the end of it
there is a carbon footprint and when you
talk of the energy optimization and the
natural resources
uh ai is the way to manage this for us
to be able to optimally utilize
um and you know conserve the energy as
well right so the energy leveling
is also one of the ai problems that we
saw so that kind of brings from
the air ops uh directly to my last slide
and i can talk
a little more use cases safe time
permitting little later but
this is a kind of a typical picture that
um you see all over and in a way i was
leading to the russian earlier right
yeah which is on the left hand side what
you see is anything coming from
bare metals to public cloud to private
cloud to a hybrid multi-cloud
today we are talking about hybrid
multi-cloud right it's not it's hybrid
because it's probably
in primary smart cloud because it's not
just one vendor
we're talking about gcpa and aws and
azure and ibm cloud and all of it coming
together right
yeah and we have the distributed
infrastructure of such kind
and distributed data centers then we're
looking at
multiple monitoring tools multiple
apm tools multiple discovery tools
multiple
capacity optimization like densifier
server over here
uh you may have dyna trace you may have
in a service now or bmc remedy or ibm
maximo or netcool whatever
so there are display tools which are
used again it's a choice which
the customers make uh which makes it
difficult from a data engineering
perspective which is what was talking
earlier right
we have the ability to get the data all
the way into creating the data pipeline
for us to be able to
curate the data and prepare the data in
the crisp and cycle for it to be used
for the analytics right
yeah and you'll see in this big box is
the whole workbench
i'll not talk about emblocks right now
but if you
just look at the volume and the velocity
of a data we're looking at 25 terabyte
of a data injection
which is actually real one that we're
handling uh which is about three to four
terabytes a day
three to four terabytes is a huge data
right yeah and then our ability to
handle the data in real time it could be
through elk stack
and again it depends on what you really
want to use right whether it's a
stack or eck stack or elk stack that
again multiple choices from a technology
perspective
uh each one of these choices will have
its own challenges i mean we do use
elastic quite often
uh and of course kibana to go with it
but then it
doesn't have to be that right because
again it has you
you'll have to write your own situations
on top of it it's univariate you have to
make it multivariate
you need to put predictor on top of it
and all of it is there right and of
course
you have to go in a cloud native way to
go into the kubernetes clusters or any
kts for that matter right
and of course today we talk about
openshift and openshift virtualization
from that perspective
but that's about the data handling the
data management data transformation
right
and then what you see is this a ops
engine and we can talk about multiple
use cases but if i just give a few of
the examples which is we talked about
anomaly detection right with multiple uh
dynamic thresholding as we call it right
or the capacity inside so again it's uh
you know if i if i just take i can take
any example but i'll just take one over
here right
because capacity inside is there it's
about not
just it's about understanding the drift
in the capacity right and the reason it
is very important shiva means
uh today as we really talk about
kovidira right in the last six months
what has gained substantial ground is
the
the dr right and the resiliency
management and from a disaster equity
perspective
what is so important is to see that
before you know
you kind of tend to lose the sync
between your primary
and your dr site because
you are really talking of cloud native
and you can have another you know
spinning off of a container coming in
or the capacity augmentation which
happens in dynamic on the way kind of
way yeah and then you are really looking
at a drift a drift in performance drift
in inventory drifting configuration
capacity and our ability to detect that
capacity to drift for us to be able to
move our rpo or an rto objective of a dr
right because you have a recurring point
objective energy for your time objective
it becomes extremely important for us to
use a dynamic backbone like an ai
backbone for us to look at capacity
insights
you know there are any other use cases
for here and then of course the
dashboarding part of it right
so i think i'll probably not go in more
details of it and dashboard can be
anything it can be angular or d3 or
reactor you know your own choice
many of the bi tools like cognos has its
own dashboarding technology but
it can be iframes right just to launch
it um in the context so
it could be different technologies but
the challenge net net from an app's
perspective is
it's about choosing the right model
maybe i'll i'll just give a very quick
glimpse of the modeling right because
that's another big part into the
ml part of it today when shum we are
really starting to look at
you know one of course the difficult
resources the data itself and i talked
about the data imputation and data
wrangling and
you know the data quality as the
challenges in data another big challenge
that we are actually facing the universe
today
is the data scientist community right
and
the reason it is of course you know as
as it is getting traction has become
more ubiquitous
uh the data scientist is becoming a rare
commodity uh the kind of sought after
community in a way
so the question is how would the
corporates today
uh take this challenge to be able to
look at uh
just do a quick time check i'll just
wrap this up so from a data science
perspective
can there be some kind of a workbench
which is a data science workbench or you
know the mlaps
which can actually choose a model train
the model
uh deploy and validate the model and
then have that continuous learning so of
course if many
workbench which is also kind of um is
gaining traction
uh and we are not the only ones but
everybody is trying to actually
wrestle that to the ground but i think
that was a long answer to aiops and i
thought that was you know
close to what i do in ibm so but i'll
delete more on that
yeah yeah i know i was that was really
helpful just deep dives definitely
helped
and in fact my next question to you was
related i
myself started a career as a data
scientist and
uh it's it's very exciting as a career
and you have already
you know covered that uh how data
analysts and data scientists can
play a role here uh being data as the
oil as the common denominator for this
uh thank you
i think uh if you want to just add to it
something or from on a roll from a data
and this data scientist perspective how
we can add more value and
how to go about it if you can add a
couple of lines to that before we move
to the next section
oh sure so you know from
the data science perspective obviously
the challenge today is to be able to
choose the right model to be able to
train it
and today we are not really talking
about choosing a model it's about
more situations specific about the
client data specific
unless you see the data you don't know
which one you're going to choose right
yeah and there are going to be
challenges of
you know the training data set and many
times you know you'll have to use some
kind of uh
the random simulation we do within monte
carlo or you know any which way that we
really do right
but the data science is you know
evolving today to
be able to take the challenges of the
world um
i would say while we really
look at the entire you know healthcare
could be one domain right if i just
speak one domain which could be very
relevant today
we have to be cognizant of the fact that
um you know the data scientists are
actually getting and gaining access to
the data we should be very confidential
data
and then uh again i come to the ethical
nature of the ai and ethical nature of
beyond the
reality is that we really need to go
with it right um
i would appeal to the people that you
know be cognizant of the fact that when
you're
playing with the data you are quite
often playing with the sensitive data
as an analyst as a data engineer or as a
data scientist
and um you know fairness or the bias is
one of the things that we do handling
airs which one
yeah it's an impending problem in a way
and there are few problems here
which so if i really give an example and
somewhere i think just two years back
you all we all must have read that
an autonomous car went into an accident
now what does it mean right who do you
catch right are there laws which are
actually supporting it
now what does it really mean that there
was a driver in the car but the car went
into an accident and
then somebody probably got injured who
are you going to sue right is it a car
manufacturer
or is it a person seated behind the
wheels but we have you know despite the
problems do not actually go touch the
wheel
so i think there are different problems
that we need to solve but um
we have to go to the state of this
autonomous city
of resiliency uh which will
ease uh and allow us to solve these
problems in a better way
yeah and there are societal aspects that
we need to be a little careful is what i
would say
got it uh so uh how about you you've
touched upon
you know ethical ai and you know uh the
the downside and upside of ai both now
in this changing world
you know uh and in this changing
scenario what would be the
top skills that uh you know any industry
would be looking for
for a for a data scientist or data
analyst and
what are the next i would say i i would
give a number but the next set of
technologies that you see are evolving
uh done down the road uh which will
which can uh you know benefit
us all both from a career and
application perspective
um i think um yes i mean if i
talk about you know what are the uh i
would say what are the technologies
right
um from a technology perspective i
believe um
there are at least few things that i can
call out right uh of course we talked
about the ai
ml and data science suspect effect uh to
an extend the age computing and iot
aspect effect
iot is becoming a reality today or it
has been a reality to an extent but
it's becoming more relevant as
the sensors actuators here in the video
surveillance cameras are becoming very
very cheap right
from us to be able to manage the threats
from us to be able to manage
uh many of the things which are humanly
not possible despite the fact that we of
course took an audience poll about being
a boon kind of thing
you know there are a few things which is
uh we can call it as
you know the social skills uh of course
the ai and the machines
are it's hard for them to have this
you know the intercultural sensitivity
which is fundamental to
the successful relationship between all
of us right particularly when you're
talking about global companies today or
cognitive skills right which is
the reasoning negotiation arguing i
would argue that arguing
is a most difficult skill actually there
is a research which is happening on that
because answering a question is easier
if you ask me and i can answer that but
argument doesn't mean that i need to
remember your answers
and i need to have some lineage to you
know what you stand for
and then be able to argue right but
argument is in making the empathy the
emotions
uh the adaptability so there are you
know different
uh creative techniques that humans use
uh
which certainly are very difficult for
it to be emulated by the machines in the
eye today
uh and of course we've got to be
cognizant of the fact that using that
as we really saw the columns today but
coming to you know a few of the
technologies i was just talking about
iot
uh the iot sensors actuators has become
more ubiquitous
uh particularly with an advent of 5g
becomes very important uh
cloud of course is one space it's a huge
huge opportunity for all of us
and uh when we go from as i said you
know the bare metals to vms to that of
uh
you know the cloud native world to that
of the function as a service or the
serverless computing world
um this renders its own opportunities of
course challenges
uh for us to actually issue the
workloads to the clouds the hybrid
multi-cloud in particular
and last but not least um blockchain i
believe it's going to change
the world the way we look at the things
today right we almost take it by default
uh so if i just give an example of a
blockchain uh you know we almost take it
by default that i go and do a purchase
with payment gateway and something
happens
uh something happens transaction aborts
i probably have to wait for another five
six days for my bank to return me the
money
because it's a bond between me and one
bank right it's not a distributed ledger
it's not a consensus basis making
uh it's a completely different system
right so i think blockchain
iot 5g ai ml and cloud would be the
technologies of the future
got it got it uh i'm also up i think we
have
next 10 minutes so we'll spend some time
on answering a few questions let me just
put forward few questions
what we have got from the audience uh so
uh you know the first question which is
very interesting is
uh while everyone is excited about ai
and how the regulations and security for
uh
frameworks evolving in this industry uh
what are your thoughts about controlled
ai uh and how is the security framework
evolving around that
oh that's an interesting question um
of course there are you know multiple
foundations and uh i kept on kind of
touching on an ethical point because
you know how is the how are the
companies trying to address it right
um and from the ethni what are the
ethical nature of it right
i was talking about you know the bias
detection for instance the fairness or
the liability or
you know if i give an example of
weaponization shivam
uh about unmanned combat aerial vehicles
for instance uh or drones for instance
right
uh there are petitions being signed by
stephen hawking smack stigma
you know many people to ban air weapons
right actually there are certain jobs
from a responsibility and morality
perspective which in certain countries
are not allowed to be done
by the ai systems which has the jobs as
a nurse
or a police or a judge right a few of
those things right
on amazon google facebook ibm and
microsoft
we have a partnership on ai ethics
in a way right which is i really want to
address this problem of
um you know the interpretability
reasoning explainability
which is not just the black box kind of
an approach but also be able to open
and be transparent and there are many
ways in which you can do it
we talk about algorithms like lime and
sharp and many things but
the whole reasoning on why a certain
decision is being taken
and the reason is becomes very important
shivam today is
very recently i shouldn't say recently i
think it's been two years
with something called hospital in
bangalore and i actually
stay out of bangalore so i know that for
the fact uh so we
um actually if i take a step back also
the biggest national mammographic grid
is created by ibm
uh which is along with the initiator
research and uh the cancer research that
we're doing with manipal which is
looking at
you know millions of patient records and
then be
able to have that kind of a reasoning
system which can detect
or which can interpret a reason that
this looks like a cancerous growth which
is humanly impossible
ai can certainly be useful there and it
can be used and should be used in that
context right so
from that perspective it is certainly
useful yeah
yeah so uh uh thank you
one more question that has come up is
and uh we spoke
uh around itsm so with
manual ticket management become obsolete
all together
down the road what are your thoughts on
it will that level of automation come
manual ticket handling yeah uh
yes if i'm getting the question correct
no human intervention like completely
insane
actually it is happening it is it is a
reality but it's at a different level
right so we have to
what necessarily we have to do is apply
a level to it right
uh so if you recall shivam at least in
india uh many many countries for that
matter
uh there was this kind of a bpo sector
and
you don't see it as much today right
yeah which is the level one ticket
handling
which is replaced by an ivr system and
not just an ivr there are these you know
the chatbots as i said right
once your knowledge corpus injection uh
some kind of illusion indexing
on top of it and you know all of it can
certainly
come to a stage at which majority of the
problems which level one issues can be
completely ticketless right then you go
to the level two part of it or level 2.5
part of it right and level two part of
it are more complex problems where you
need uh you needed human intervention
to an extent it's been automated which
is automation like cc and rcp
and you know the ib soft automation and
robotic process automation like you know
blueprism or automation anywhere all of
those comes in right
uh however as it crosses the level two
it becomes that you know the expertise
that one needs to have under domain
expertise
any ai system needs a domain expertise
right and even if you really infuse the
domain expertise
it's not as much as you know today our
subject matter experts carrying
so i would say the level three cons are
certainly not completely automated and
it will not be ticketless
that's the kind of nirvana state that we
want to be and it's evolving towards
that
but that's still a distant mirage i
would say
got it got it so one one more related
question
to get i got uh is uh how will
the roles of a data scientist analyst
look like in this field
if all the diagnosis and all the
recommendation will happen through
recommendation engines dashboards what
will be a role of a
data scientist in this evolving
ecosystem once we reach that nirvana
i think uh very interesting very
interesting question right
first and foremost you know if i uh
ridiculous that it may sound but if i
just go back right
there is this always a debate uh which
is nothing new shivam
when i was young i had the same debate
because you know many of my
contemporaries were having the same
debate which is
is computerization going to approve the
humans from the jobs right
is it a threat hence right uh so while
we say that
all of these data scientists data
analysts and data engineers knowledge
community doing data scientists
if it is already becoming cognitive the
systems are there why do you need the
data science anymore right or data
scientists or people anymore
it has to be looked at from perspective
and abortionity because this is an
evolution
so if i just look at you know what my
grandfather was doing or your
grandfather was doing
probably they were almost trapped in
farming there was no other job than
farming right
there are many of the jobs which we
haven't we could not have thought about
which are coming today
so this opportunity renders itself to
completely new cedar jobs
which are going to be coming in and
which have started happening already and
which will always happen right it's not
just now but it should always happen
right
so it could be jobs in aviation industry
and the insurance industry and the
health care industry and the education
industry and tnt industry and whatever
it is right many of the jobs did not
exist 50 years man
and these this is something which we
probably didn't do an envy stage
happening which is happening today right
so none of these are doing actually
majority of the farmers are actually
coming to cities today
to do few data so long story short what
i would say is that the ubiquitous
nature of the ai ml which is coming into
all walks of life
uh made the insurance industry um
the transportation industry education
industry right i mean the simplest thing
which haunts you today is you which is
called the syndrome of you know the
market basket analysis right
uh the biggest crime that you do today
is one crime could be
a parking vehicle on 10 downing street
and another is obviously
you know abandoning your shopping cart
because you know when the queen is gonna
prosecute here
otherwise somebody is gonna haunt you by
throwing promotions and promotions after
you
why did you abandon your shopping cart
right so that's an ai which is actually
haunting you right unfortunately
unfortunately but all of this cross-sale
upsell this evolution of the
opportunities
is only going to grow for the data
science as a discipline so it's a bright
future for data science
and data engineer and the data analyst
yeah
uh but even even if you don't you talked
about that debate i still have that
event with me
but yes get into that uh so uh yes but
but we we do understand that with this
evolution of the ecosystem
and uh this this whole uh machine
learning ai
are getting involved there are a lot of
opportunities opening up with new areas
completely right there one last question
about on on that front end i think
i wanted to touch upon in detail and
around ethical ai but i think we can
cover here with this last question
this is an interesting question that you
talked about ai ops right
and uh and and then there is something
called uh
you know a field of cyber security which
which make sure
uh that your data is protected and you
know your pii data and all that
is completely protected uh what
what happens when cyber security and ai
ops
merge uh they they marry uh and
are there any downsides to it what if ai
plays the other way around
you have a you have a wrong
recommendation or something and it it
it plays the other way around what what
happens in that scenario what are the
downsides
that's a very very interesting question
and
um you know i would say the downside is
there on
no matter which system you're talking
about right and which domain you're
talking about right
we could argue that from a medical
diagnosis perspective or you know the
example which i gave right which is a
driverless car
uh the upside of it is that quite often
uh
for the company that i work for which is
ibm i have a lot of evening calls in
india which is
morning time in u.s likes to earn these
days it is so common that people have
their laptops like this and a video call
with me which is you know early morning
and they're driving on 101 in california
right uh 101 is like our
state highway or rather the interstate
highway in india right
yeah and it's that sheer confidence
which is they're driving the car which
is a great thing but then there's a
downside to it right
because there will be one such
completely new situation that could be
given to that autonomous car
uh where it can unfortunately not behave
properly right so there is a downside to
everything
right and wherever you require of course
there's going to downside
but talking about the security of course
the
the the authenticity and the
authorization and the security has been
tightened over the years
in multiple ways i mean not just with
128
you know bit encryption on the kerberos
securities kind of a thing but the
different password walls and different
oauths and
different ways in which the role-based
accesses in the iot systems are managed
which is called our backs and stuff for
that kind right
uh but no matter what we really do
and um you know we sure the way we
really try to protect ourselves and
safeguard ourselves in any iit system
there are at the end of the day some
software programs right
and of course there are going to be some
smart cookies which are going to be able
to hack it
so we have to be on our toes no matter
what whether there is air whether it is
you know
human software shield that you're really
trying to put up which is
in the dmz zone with all the security
firewall around it
uh air otherwise security threat is
looming launch particularly so
when we're really talking of many of the
digital identities and the digital
life in a way in the digital ecosystem
it becomes extremely difficult uh
because you know you are seen in sci-fi
movies that your identity can be
completely
wiped off the face of earth and then you
become a fugitive
right and um now that's not happening
today which is fortunately so but
it can happen right i mean all those
science fictions can actually become a
reality
uh so there is a threat no doubt about
it and we have to be vigilant about it
uh so you know i get reminded of one
thing when i used to stay out of the u.s
young let me just quote that and maybe
stuart can relate to it
yeah there used to be this kind of uh
you know the speed detectors
of the car and the the cops in the us
used to actually plant it near the
bridge or under the bridge or something
like that
where when you really speed up that can
actually detect
right that device can detect your speed
and then the market started selling
something called the device anti-device
can actually jam the device right it's
like the antenna jammers
and cops came up with anti-anti-jammers
right and then the shop started selling
anti-anti-anti-german
so where does it stop right because a
bits b
and then again so it's the same thing in
security right you stand in the security
and people beat and you strengthen it
again that's an evolution
yeah yeah yeah uh
thank you i think this this was a very
fruitful conversation we
will be taking a lot with us uh you gave
a very
very deep uh analysis of the itsm
and uh the whole industry and not only
confined to idsm we talked about
ethically we talked about downsides
upside of ai but whatever be the case i
think this ecosystem is evolving
uh and we as data scientists as data
engineers and
a lot of uh you know people uh as as
part of this webinar
aspiring to be those future data
scientists data will definitely benefit
a lot from it there is potential and
will definitely leverage on that any any
any closing thoughts about before we
uh say goodbye no it's been an
interesting session uh shivan and stuart
and thanks for the opportunity
uh we from ibm uh usually as i said you
know quantum is just one of the examples
are at the forefront of
many of these technologies uh and i
believe it's a technology which
uh including has to help uh the humanity
at large and while we use these tools in
our hands and you know many of the young
data scientists who are part of this
webinar
uh the only humble request to the entire
societal appeal i would say
is that we have to use these tools
carefully
and we have to be uh cognizant of the
fact that
it can be the beginner boom right so we
have to kind of pave the way for the
societal
well-being in general and these tools
have to be very
judiciously used uh towards the better
of the humanity than otherwise
definitely definitely yeah thank you all
for your time
uh thank you stuart over to you
thank you
all right and and i want to i want to
thank both amal and xium
for a fascinating discussion we got way
more questions
than possibly answered in the webinar
and uh we will try to put together a
document that we can share with the
attendees
that will help answer a few more of
those
you will receive a link to
a webinar recording in your email and
for those of you who have attended
live today congratulations you will also
receive a proof of attendance
certificate by email um i've got
maul's linkedin information here but you
can also just do a search for him
and i want to invite everyone to join us
next week
for a webinar
on in the digital marketing space
for those of you who are involved in
digital marketing this is top things to
know now about seo
with matt bailey of sitelogic who is one
of our
faculty advisors at simplylearn
and our follow-up email to this webinar
will include a link to that
registration page if you're not uh
involved in digital marketing but know
someone who is
just pass that along to them and you can
contact simply learn connect with us on
facebook twitter linkedin all the social
platforms we do thank you all for
joining us today and this concludes our
webinar
so we will be um on mute from this point
on
and we invite you to log off if you see
a survey
come up in your web browser please do
answer the questions it will help us
improve the webinars and future and
again thanks everyone
thank you
you